el príncipe Harry inició esta
comparecencia sin precedentes porque el
último miembro de la familia real que
estuvo sentado en el banquillo en una
corte entregando su testimonio fue el
príncipe Alberto en el siglo 19 el hijo
mayor de la reina Victoria que luego se
convertiría en Rey el príncipe Harry
inició con una declaración de 55 páginas
bien emotivas en las que entre otras
hace referencias a la muerte de su madre
la princesa Diana Quien murió en un
accidente de tránsito en París en 1997
mientras era perseguida por paparazzis
pero Harry también detalló como la
persecución de los tabloides afectado su
vida desde que es un niño dijo que el
periodismo necesita ser salvado
exponiendo a quienes han robado
secuestrado los privilegios y poderes de
la prensa insinuó que los periódicos los
tabloides tienen sangre en sus manos y
ha dicho que gente ha muerto como
resultado de las historias y que otros
suicidándose dijo palabras bien fuertes
cuanta más sangre manchará sus dedos
antes de que alguien pueda poner fin a
esta locura el príncipe Harry para este
caso ha seleccionado
147 artículos y ha elegido como
evidencia 33 en los que asegura que la
información fue obtenida utilizando
herramientas ilegales como la
interceptación de sus llamadas
telefónicas acceso al buzón de mensajes
que tenía información privilegiada
confidencial incluso sobre su propia
seguridad y también contratando a
investigadores privados para que
consiguieran información exclusiva sobre
el príncipe Harry a cualquier costo